now to an horrific tragedy here in new
york city and horrific is the word at
least 19 people are dead this morning
after what appears to be the deadliest
residential fire in the u.s in more than
30 years to make it worse nine of the
victims are children officials blame a
malfunctioning space heater for the fire
which also injured dozens of people in
this building nancy chen has more on the
story
dramatic video shows new york
firefighters lowering a stretcher to the
ground on it one of the more than 60
people injured in sunday's tragic fire
firefighters
are trying their best
officials say the fire started in a
two-story unit on the second and third
floors the flames only damaged the
apartment and nearby hallways but with
the door to the apartment left open
smoke escaped and began to fill the
entire 120 unit building black black
smoke i could barely see from me to you
it was very heartbreaking especially
when you see kids like fighting for
their life
while some got out dozens were trapped
inside forced to smash windows for air
members found victims on
every floor in stairways and were taking
them out
in cardiac and respiratory arrest about
200 firefighters responded sunday
fighting the flames evacuating survivors
and resuscitating the injured many
continued searching in the smoke even as
their oxygen tanks emptied according to
mayor eric adams this is a horrific
horrific painful moment for the city of
new york
this is going to be one of the worst
fires that we have witnessed
during modern times
city officials say that the children
killed in this fire were all under the
age of 16. 18 people remain hospitalized
this morning some residents say that at
first they ignored the sound of smoke
alarms because false alarms are common
in their building nate
thoughts and prayers with those families
nancy thank you